all right how does it feel to be back
together and why was it important for
all of you to be here for this this is
the first ever 90s con yes and we were
invited to be here as a little reunion
for us to get together and it's so it's
so special for all of us to connect
again and uh we take every opportunity
we can to get together really we just
loved each other we loved working
together it was really special seven
years i always say people talk about
their high school years for the rest of
their lives and that's only four years
and we had seven so it's like yeah
that's true you know a lot of people had
seven years of high school
sabrina
you should listen to you guys and trust
your advice right
and realize that it's easier to solve
problems when i ask for help exactly and
always know that my family is there for
me right man i am good who's the glue
that holds everybody together
you do you keep in touch with everybody
okay i love life and you coordinate you
plan things she's our julia the love
boat right there i am hello you come
aboard
here's who you're gonna mate with this
time um no so we yeah i like to throw
parties i like to keep people together i
like to connect and so we do it whenever
we can and this is a great opportunity
for that it's a great opportunity to
connect with the fans and kind of like
you know be able to interact with them
and and it's an excuse for all of us to
be together why do you think the show
resonated like it did so much because
wouldn't you like to have magical powers
and wouldn't you like to have an
all-powerful teenager who's just
learning how to be powerful raised by
the coolest ants with the cutest boy and
the nicest and the nemesis
hold on
nice no but it was in real life it was
like who wouldn't i want you know i
didn't watch it until my daughter was
seven and then we watched an episode i
immediately called her like you were so
good
because we we never watched it we were
saying we were too busy we literally
worked for however many years nobody
ever saw it well people are shocked when
we say we never saw it and i was like
but the but the thing is like friday
nights we work till 2 a.m a long time
this is before dvr or hulu you know we
did vhs on friday morning and say here's
tonight's episode and you think i'm
going to go on saturday morning when i
get home
and pop one in the tape and maybe
because i was a producer but they pop it
in the pop it in the thing and watch my
show when i just got done with work and
i got to go back monday like that's
worked i'm not doing that so i've never
watched it now i watch it i have seen it
so adorable yeah you forgot to mention
the cat the 500 year old cat
[Music]
salem
are you being sincere
yes and it pains me to do it
okay would you be out for a reunion
special a reunion special yeah yeah i
guess so it depends on what it would
look like of course we'd want to do it
it just depends on like can i use that
to do the entire show
on an instagram filter the truth is the
cat is more uh popular than all of us so
we just kind of keep we ignore them yeah
how do you think it changed your lives
professionally and personally this show
this is the greatest gift i would say
one of the greatest gifts of my entire
life getting to be on this show it gave
us access to children all over the world
i'm sure like these guys i used to go
and visit children's hospitals every
every kid was happy to see you and you
could make a kid's day by just showing
up it is and and look at us we're it's
20 how many years later you guys wow 25
years later 19 years 19 years
since it went off
yes
she makes fun of me
i swear to you a day does not go by when
someone calls me aunt hilda and i just
answer yeah yeah people will ask me
what's a favorite job you've ever done
because i've done tons of series and
movies and stuff i'm always like the one
that makes kids all over the world happy
that one yeah that's my favorite yeah
and you two did the chilling adventures
yes sabrina is that you
well there you are where were you we
were getting worried not me i haven't
been worried since bottomless mimosas
what was that like i will confess that i
sometimes on occasion perhaps you guys
agree i don't always read all of the
stage directions unless i'm actually
directing the episode so it wasn't until
maybe day three that i realized we were
going to eat people and then i was like
i'm not going to eat anyone and neither
is she it was my new canadian lovely
canadian extras who can gorge those
people but we'll be over here on our
children's show it got dark it's very
dark yeah and we were very good we were
like what
we were like wow this is weird
but they all grew up watching our show
and so when we did the table read and i
was like sabrina is that you
they all went
you know because they grew up wasn't
that your first line yeah it was the
first time in the series where would
your characters be today
oh gosh
can i take somebody
what a very successful mechanic with his
own garage or something like that
wouldn't he be married oh yeah i'm
talking about you man oftentimes
no no we got the before you know what
happens a week later yeah you are so
happily married in
i
my
mind
in a wedding dress
yeah the other guy met you at the uh uh
in vegas and uh
definitely ever after for you guys not
marry that other guy
libby would be steamrolling over every
committee and pta and chairing college
reunions
and um
you know thinking that she was just as
nice as she always did
i think uh you know everybody talks all
the time about you know what a what a a
reboot would look like and is it that
you know if we're married do we have
kids that then find out that they have
powers and how we kept that from them
and
then the green ants come along and did
you just call me ingredient i'm gonna
i would definitely be in education you
know teaching in the other realm and
zelda was so you would probably be into
like oh you could be in this realm you'd
probably be at like harvard you'd be
like dumbledore of the other round
exactly
i think we have a lot of ideas
let's do it who are you playing i mean
whoever you want you're in charge you
tell me
maybe you come in as the bad girl and
then that makes you nice
maybe libby had a complete like epiphany
and and
people are always surprised when they do
meet me in real life because they're
like oh you're not mean you're so sweet
because they think you're going to be
turn them in people always think i'm
going to be the
nastiest it's so much fun playing nasty
absolutely
abs who wouldn't love to go to work
every single day and get to say things
that are just
horrible
and you get paid to do it and get away
with it and get away the reason why you
think it's fun though is because you're
so nice in real life if you were nasty
in real life you wouldn't think it was
funny i always say this i do not think
the the mean girl from high school could
ever play mean because she doesn't think
she's mean so she doesn't recognize what
that is the perpetrator always thinks
they're the victim or the savior they
never think they're the perpetrators
exactly
the me and girl never think she's the
mean girl so you would never be able to
to do it unless you observed it that's
right and you did it well yeah people do
the boys think about their mom being
melissa joan hart okay so it's weird
like they're they're just like like the
14 year olds getting to the point where
he's like okay i can enjoy this a little
bit like i can use this
and then there's a little bit of like
the little one the nine-year-old has
started using with his teacher well i
don't have to do my homework because my
mom's showing her like oh no
oh my god no seriously that doesn't
matter that's hilarious he's dry though
it's a nice try he's very clever
actually i made them watch our pancake
episode because i was trying to explain
sugar addiction to my little one oh no
more i need more
but it don't sit in there for any big
game
you were hilarious in that episode i
just watched it because it was pancake
tuesday yeah yeah you are really funny
that was my favorite cause i think it's
the first time i really got to really
play physical comedy i felt like
and i realized that i loved that and i
wanted to do more of that
[Music]
you